incroyable que l'autorisation ait été
délivrée alors certes le maire a dit oui
et le problème c'est que les instances
de l'État ont mal protégé le site c'est
ça mais ce sont des menhirs qui sont à
Carnac la zone la plus incroyable au
niveau de ces sites là il fallait les
protéger aujourd'hui ils sont détruits
et pourquoi ils sont détruits je vais
vous donner la vraie raison c'est parce
que le propriétaire qui va construire le
magasin de bricolage il a autour une
enseigne de supermarchés il a retour une
station de lavage un magasin
d'électroménager une station-service
donc il a préempté la zone le maire a
été impuissant et moi je trouve que
c'est un scandale écologique il y a une
planque qui a été déposée pour
destruction volontaire j'espère que
cette plante ira très loin on ne va pas
reconstruire les menhirs mais il faut
arrêter la destruction voilà ministre de
la Culture elle peut pas parler là
justement il faudrait ça il faudrait il
y a pas de mobilisation étatique mais
pour qu'il y ait une une autorisation
comme ça de la mairie sur un site qui
est protégé et qui en plus inscrit enfin
inscrit sur la liste de fonctions au
patrimoine de l'Unesco est-ce qu'il y a
pas eu genre des pots de vin les
êtres humains sont complètement
déconnectés de la nature parce que
au-delà des menhirs de la construction
les menhirs c'est énergétiquement
parlant en fait on y va pour mettre nos
mains sur les menus
[Rires]
j'adore mettre mes mains sur lui comme
ça ça me fait de l'énergie
vous vous rendez compte la quête de
l'argent fait que finalement on oublie
c'est comme les chamanes et chamanes la
terre les forêts qu'on comme ça qu'on
détruit etc et c'est minières-là en fait
amène aussi une haute vibration
énergétique sur le site c'est pour ça
aussi que les habitants les protègent
c'est pas juste des cailloux et c'est ça
la différence c'est que il y a certaines
personnes qui me voient que des cailloux
et d'autres qui voient vraiment un site
archéologique tous les menhirs sont
placés de telle façon que finalement ça
réhausse toute la vibration énergétique
je voudrais quand même donner le démenti
du maire lui il explique en fait le
titre comme ça et surtout non mais les
photos ne sont pas du tout celles de ce
qui a été détruite en fait c'est un
petit muret avec 39 pierres mais des
pierres comme ça qui sont très anciennes
bien sûr il y en a des milliers dans
Carnac il y en a quatre éventuellement
qui sont intéressantes archéologiquement
parlant qui ont été mises de côté donc
franchement c'est ça reste quand même un
alignement inédite c'est quand même de
la désinformation ne serait-ce que par
les photos parce qu'on a l'impression
que voilà il a relevé vraiment de
menhirs comme ça et ça n'est pas du tout
le cas ce matin j'ai vu une photo c'est
un petit muret malgré tout malgré tout
on peut simplement
l'appareil
c'est pas leur histoire
mais tu as bien fait le meilleur parce
que ça là c'est ça le c'est ça
l'histoire
bien fait de l'enlever
c'est magnifique
merci Daniel
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
à l'emploi il y a des salariés qui vont
travailler qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire
que tu voulais dire non
on a privilégié l'emploi on a on a
détruit pour pouvoir construire quelque
chose les habitants vont trouver du
travail
c'est limite si tu leur regard emploi
vous êtes aventurer sur une phrase un
petit peu compliquée
là franchement ça y est c'est salé c'est
ça les 38 milliards hein les gars vous
voyez le pouvoir de la désinformation
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut nous montrer la photo
du point formation
regardez regardez la malhonnêteté
là
c'est quoi cette malhonnêteté 39 menhirs
et tu vois le truc après mettez la photo
non mais mettez la photo
[Applaudissements]
quelle connerie tu racontes non mais
attends là il a cru la photo tout le
monde parce que tout le monde a cru un
autre photo que celle-ci est la bonne
mais ça va parce que Daniel Moreau
les mecs vous croyez vraiment que c'est
ça mais ça c'est le point et alors le
point arrête de défendre tes amis les
journalistes arrête un peu tu
retravailleras pas avec eux
je reprendront jamais arrête
tous les articles sont mensonges
ou quoi
Gilles Verdez j'ai mon téléphone je peux
vous montrer mon téléphone